[Musique]
alors sur six belles images de béton
armé du canada et de la nature
canadienne
bienvenue à tintin canada en direct de
montréal c'est vendredi c'est la
tradition c'est le 23 ou aujourd'hui et
autour de la table on est choyé on a
trois autres amis de radio canada
international marie claude simard
bonjour orange en tout le monde raymonde
et marc bonjour bonjour et il ne fait
l'insigne honneur encore une fois
bonjour
bon stéphane dondon vraiment et pendant
lequel les bons jours ça c'est une fusée
prêté par la section arabe de radio
canada international samir ben bonjour
alors écoutez vous aussi vous ne
connaissez rien à ces notions ne suis
pas au courant de tous au même niveau
alors on regarde ensemble que nous
internautes vous allez d'essayer de
deviner le sujet la démission
aujourd'hui c'est notre vidéo 5 images
et vous fait quel enthousiasme
alors voici une autre vidéo 5 images et
il ya vous cesser de crier à voir la
cinquième image quel est le sujet de
l'émission aujourd'hui on regarde son
ensemble alors là promettant à ses
septembre wind sa fenêtre septembre
alors voilà ouais donc si je mens et
l'exercice physique
les enfants c'est relié jeu dopage
non non mais ça oui oui oui les régimes
minceur non plus canadiens japonais de
ça mais je pense que c'est
lorsque l'alimentation oui c'est bien ça
raymond et est pratiquement alimentation
way alimentation et cissé qui tenait à
ce que fait le belkin dans l'assiette
contradictions la fameuse remarqué là
j'ai mis une belle fille aussi du
possible mais j'ai vu un homme à la fin
pour ce jeu c'est d'attirer toutes les
cotes d'écouté possible respecte tout le
spectre voilà tout le monde d'accord
c'est un studio
c'est fantastique alors ça c'est le
sujet aujourd'hui la diète c'est aux
jeunes qui fait des millions d'adeptes
par ceux de mon canada parce que
seulement 37 millions d'habitants au
canada mais qui fait des millions
d'adeptes dans le monde et certains
m'ont dit oui monsieur en fait tu l'as
dit à kinston à remanier un peu les
choses
c'est une diète en fait qui existe
depuis des années vingt mille neuf cent
vingt ans au siècle dernier
1922 en fait tout 21 faudra vérifier
avec nos experts aujourd'hui qui seront
sur skype et elle a beaucoup progressé
au plan de la science cette diète mais
encore beaucoup de critiques à son égard
puisque l'objectif c'est de remplacer le
gras il ya un mot pour cent en
laboratoire ces multiples élite et puis
vous avez fait aux études en sciences
ils ont rappelé à sa part quoi ce
bonheur en fait on va place des glucides
donc les jeux sid parakh la voilà ne
partons pas de rumeurs c'est la nouvelle
ocm sucre le sucre par le gr voilà j'ai
une petite vidéo pour vous montrer à
quel point ben en avant vous présenter
la vidéo c'est quoi le mot le bon et
beau les bonnes actions
c'est notre premier tour de la grosse
boule aujourd'hui il est responsable de
la bonne tenue de la boule c'est quoi
votre titre déjà vous avez dit raymond
serra alors voici ya trois jeux à
l'émission vous perdez des boules ou
voulait garder au fur et à mesure de la
conversation
aujourd'hui on affiche la première
question de sept premiers tours 20
boules à perdre un canadien sur la diète
cétogène doit limiter sa consommation de
glucides à combien de grammes par jour
d'abord je vous donne un point de
référence 600 grammes c'est la
consommation moyenne
canada par jour d'accord en suisse un
gramme alors il doit limiter sa
consommation à quoi à 300 g b 200 g
ces 100 g que l'équivalent d'une
tablette de chocolat ou encore où une
petite comme chez moi nous d aucune de
ces réponses
aucune de ces réponses pour moi moi je
dirais c'est c'est alors b alors 200 et
100 grammes sont des choix populaire mde
également way très bien aucune de ces
réponses pourquoi ce que j'imagine qu'il
faudra aller plus bas
sa plus basse pour la bonne réponse on
affiche on affiche la bonne réponse les
petites étoiles vont apparaître
voilà ça peut arriver
alors notre héros loeb conserve ses
boules c'est bien pour les autres c'est
je sais pas s'il allait à 0 mais c'est
bien sûr l'idéal mais ça je sais pas
c'est risqué je pense écoutez vous voyez
vous je vous montre à quel point on
réduit parce que vous dites zero non
mais regardons la vidéo numéro 2
aujourd'hui j'ai appelé ça le tableau
des références régime montrer ce qu'on
consomme en moyenne dans un régime
ordinaire et mordit nerfs est un mot
facile la main et un régime cétogène
donc voilà alors nous comparaison des
pourcentages dans un régime ordinaire
sans dany [ __ ] et 50 % de glucides et la
diète c'est aux jeunes au cours du camp
d'entraînement il faut réduire à 30
grammes seulement sa consommation de
sucre de deux piscines c'est philippe
ducher gagnent partout
la dernière chose qui s'est pas jouée
sur une barre de chocolat les glucides
en justice voilà c'est ce qui était
intéressant vous dit que j'allais dans
les glucides les outils captivé par le
sujet inquiète pas d'excusés alors ce
qui est intéressant dans tout ça c'est
que il ya beaucoup de gens qui
critiquent sa diète
là on n'est pas là pour critiquer pour
le moment on va aller vers quelqu'un
moyens le co auteur d'un livre sur cette
question là l et es con là sur skype
aujourd'hui au téléphone
quelle est la situation chef john 120 on
va s'en rendre compte à l'instant oui on
travaille fort sur mon éviter j'espère
qu'elle n'est pas encore cinq à
l'hôpital cols bleus ainsi que quatre
bleus ouais c'est prix ne connaissez pas
vous comble c'est une crise cardiaque
s'il est pris d'assaut
c'est faire l'hôpital on n'est pas rendu
là alors notre invité aujourd'hui et
josey arsenault coauteur perdre du poids
en mangeant du gras avec l'alimentation
c'est aux jeunes parce qu'il faut
ajouter du gras à l'alimentation de vue
ce livre vous savez vous-mêmes fait une
critique peut-être non non perçus non
j'avais pas fais d'entrevue sinon plus
non plus mais mon dieu je vous le laisse
c'est à votre tour
voilà en tout cas le plat il est
délicieux le bacon j'en ai la maison mon
surpoids souvent congèle parce que sinon
c'est un jeu c'est ce que je pense et
gic ma façon difficile d'adhérer à ça au
début parce qu'on a tellement entendu
dire qu'il ne faut pas manger de
renverser ça c'est pas évident on va
écouter
ben je sais pas si j'agis une copine pas
une copine d'une nièce qui est elle m'a
raconté ça à noël ils étaient fiers de
m'en parler m'a dit que c'est très
difficile
elle avait arrêté au moment où elle m'en
parlait c'était normal parce que c'était
ses traits du céleste régnant équin
quand tu arrêtes mal de tête c'est
difficile pour l'accord je veux voir si
notre invité josey arsenault et
finalement avec nous au téléphone
peut-être on essaie maintenant de
contacter par téléphone très bien sûr ma
marche le téléphone c'est fiable en a
marre senaux avant de nous lancer dans
des grandes discussions sur vos
expériences personnelles concernant la
diète c'est aux jeunes vous êtes une
personne connue dans les milieux
médiatiques je pense au niveau
radiophonique particulièrement ceux
admis m depuis 28 ans maintenant
fantastique dans une personne de métier
il ya rien votre épreuve
avez vous goûté pour la première fois le
principe de la diète c'est aux jeunes
parce que vous aviez fait une entrevue
avec quelqu'un comment est ce que vous
pouvez commencer à vous familiariser
avec ce phénomène finalement est un
phénomène de société maintenant oui mais
en fait c'est pas connu du tout du tout
au québec ça dans ma voiture que j'ai
entendu le médecin est venu me voir en
entrevue parler des grands principes
moi je vais beaucoup de poids à perdre à
cette époque là donc c'est vraiment
cherché par cette une grande pour
vendredi mais les leurs
le next est possible de perdre du poids
en mangeant ce gr donc ça m'a parlé et
tout de suite après j'ai commencé
justement à l'expérimenté à travers
plusieurs recherches sur ce processus de
distance c'est quand même très connu
puis il y avait déjà plusieurs médecins
qui avaient écrit sur le sujet aussi
agent faune particulièrement en suisse
cette année colloque torontois que fait
une vingtaine d'années de tout l'appui
code d'hésiter connaissait peut-être
temps que j'ai fait beaucoup de lecteurs
le fasse des personnes pourront pas
traitée de folle j'ai commencé à
cuisiner avec plus par là que j'ai
commencé à travailler ici
si le j'étais comme dans un moment
d'euphorie il s'est opposé qui la
première semaine j'ai perdu cinq lits le
joker fais quand même intéressant la
deuxième donateur peut pas continuer
puis le j'ai commencé à en discuter dans
mon entourage à la radio qu'il aurait
été comme ça que j'ai eu l'idée d'écrire
le livre avec des réveils bourg de la
revue la demande à ce sujet et à quel
moment et vous tombez malade
non mais moi j'ai les pauvres qui
peuvent parler du thé au flou parce que
c'est normal à notre carte du push up
parce qu'habituellement on consomme en
général au québec en 3 500 grammes de
glucide par jour puis moi comme un
objectif à la perte de projets
s'adressent à 20 grammes et -29 tort ici
car même heure chocle le moisi plus vite
eu la fébrilité l'euphorie l'énergie
popu par contre 6,0 à quel point qu'elle
le fera plus de glucides dans ma journée
mais le ressenti peut vous vous imposez
une discipline ce que les contraignant
dans la vie quotidienne normale avec la
peau avec des légumes va écouter je vous
pose la question quand vous arrivez à
vous retrouver avec les 20 g
de glucides est-ce que vous avez un
instrument de mesure avec vous je sais
pas oui et des actes spectaculaires
donne pour les valeurs nutritives de
tous les aliments c'est vraiment très
intéressant mais pour ceux qui veulent
pas forcément dans le stress la d'avoir
calculé mon assiette typique c'est
toujours une protéine de la grosseur de
la paume de la main et légumes verts à
volonté puis il rajoute du grog du
profit négrette maiana cinq hommes se
sont toujours assurés d'avoir mon 20
grammes et moi merci
est ce que en cours de vote
éventuellement lorsque le poids idéal et
atteint celui que vous ciblez est-ce
qu'il va y avoir un moment donné une
période de sevrage qui doit s'impliquer
mais pour début que la selle c'est vrai
oui parce qu'il ya des gens qui comptent
en effet prenons l'exemple typique la
québécois qui prend cinq fois grand
domaine à 300 grandes banques us par
jour qui prend de la liqueur qui prend
ce but qui pense bien faire quand même
qui mange des pâtes frites coupe le feu
qui coupe les glucides
c'est là que la période de kétou cloud
lequel période de sevrage
mais à partir d'un certain temps on
devise c'est tout adapté qu'on appelle
dans notre corps fonctionne très bien
qui est juste les bienfaits que ça nous
a même fait on ne peut pas envie de
revenir en arrière et puis tout est très
important de savoir c'est qu'on ne peut
pas retourner en arrière une décision on
va prendre pour le long terme oui
d'accord c'est comme arrêter de fumer
exactement exactement et qu'en est il du
vin par des mois ne crée pas le droit de
lever mais fram en vain ce n'est pas
parce que mais pour faire des bons choix
parce que vous allez y et des bouteilles
de vin qui peut y avoir jusqu'à 50
grammes
mais moi les les fois que je fais
maintenant c'est les 2 grammes et moins
pour kona ligoté par exemple du bon vin
porte ou yaya plusieurs choix s'offrent
à nous a t elle dans une dernière
question pour vous mais encore une fois
c'est quelqu'un qui sait pas
écoutez on entrait profond jackson
tout le monde avait à voir son poids
idéal
j'avais fait un peu de jeu toujours
intéressé par une nouvelle diète
effectivement j'avais lu un peu puisque
des gestes un peu loin d'hama dans ma
mémoire mais il ya quand même des mises
en garde
il est pas comme un genre de un moment
donné si tu fais pas exactement
correctement ça peut créer plus de
points nocif que positif est ce que tu
nous parler un peu toi je sais que ça
touche tout comme question mais il ya
quand même des mises en garde quand on
décide de la garder pour les gens mais
si des gens augmentent leurs gros parce
qu'ils veulent vivre un été pourri dans
chaque fois que je n'ai avec ça mais qui
baye fall of duty beloeil vont prendre
pour proposer maintenant on peut
connaître ferme a mal fait parce que on
est tellement déprimant on prend des
légumes par an volonté on a nos produits
et notre énergie on va la chercher dans
les grottes que au début a fait une
adaptation de pour le corps mais à
partir du moment où est-ce qu'on essaie
tout adapté il y en a pas vraiment
problème par contre ceux qui sont
électriques de type 1 doivent être
suivis par un médecin et l'eau peut-être
la mise en garde
mais quelqu'un quelque part relativement
normale dès que des pieds qu'est ce que
vous entendez par cet os adapté ce
justement c'est un gars pas encore est
habitué à voir et qui est capable de
fonctionner avec l'egypte du tout cuit
par très bien madame arsenault on va se
quitter vous tombez déjà dans des
considérations médicales
nous avons une perte qui va nous parler
de ça reste à d'ailleurs une amie de
deux très belles transitions jose aux
bonnes chances bonne je le pense je
m'arrête bonne journée à radio côte à
perdre du poids en mangeant à l'élection
alors écoutez action c'est que c'est
quand même
c'est adapté voici la deuxième 2ème tour
de la grosse boule comme bull à perdre
par an 30 sur un total de 100 il a gardé
ses premières 20 boules sert aux log et
à vous êtes attentif quand tout le monde
bon voici c'est très drôle 7,7 la diète
cétogène ont dit qu'elles laquelle aide
à régler certains problèmes médicaux
aviv où sa dent très sérieux est ce que
ca on affiche la question à l'antenne le
diabète est ce que ces bébés
le cancer est ce que c'est c'est
l'épilepsie moi j'irai pour le sais
parce que le diable est elle avait mis
les mises en examen vous diriez c'est
l'école aussi bon et je veux dire ah
parce que peut-être que si on la fait
bien justement un peu aidé le diabète
c'est vrai ce pour le ti pas ti pas
c'est qu'il ya des recommandations
savez-vous moi je retiens c'est que vous
avez peut-être raison j'ai lu quelque
chose à ce sujet là il y en a environ
qu'on pouvait guérir le diabète de type
1 en chargeant son alimentation de façon
drastique font des rites et lada sous
toute réserve
vraiment l'épilepsie l'épilepsie voyez
un consensus au moins ici de vote sur
trois pour l'épilepsie
j'ai bien compris je veux pas faire fi
de votre réponse a alors je vais vous
donner à gratin pour vous donnez vous
vos vins bull
il ya deux bonnes réponses b le cancer
et ses l'épilepsie d'accord c'est devenu
un bon pour ce qui est du diabète il va
falloir attendre notre spécialiste nook
et que voici
bah elle est sur notre ère jusqu'à dr
evelyne bord du roi bonjour alors
dites-moi est-ce qu'elle garde ses vins
ball est ce que ça peu ses 2 2 ça peut
aider les diabétiques de faire une diète
c'est un gène
oui en effet l'alimentation français de
l'alimentation c'est aux jeunes pour
aider à renverser ou à mieux contrôler
mieux gérer le diabète de type 1 et le
diabète de type 2 est en effet passé
une bonne nouvelle ça tout point à
maintenant les vraies bonnes nouvelles
d'accord parce que vous êtes habitué
dans le temps les moyens bonne nouvelle
parce que vous avez écrit là-dessus et
il ya eu des réactions au québec
car comme il y en a partout dans le
monde des réactions à chaque fois que
quelqu'un dit voilà une diète qui est un
nouveau mode de vie j'ai une longue
liste ici j'ai retrouvé sur wikipédia
donc c'est peut-être pas tout vrai
c'était très fort mais on dit qu'il ya
des problèmes des fois ceux ci à celle
là il ya des mots compliqués c'est comme
une liste unique hyper lippé me
hypercholestérolémie lice calculs rénaux
perte de poids soit 510 me nourris ou le
lof diminution de la densité osseuse est
inquiétant augmentation du risque de
fracture de fatigue ça va avec wi fi des
factures aussi il ya des factures ça
demain quelque part si on achète
beaucoup d'aliments gras ça coûte cher
des fois le fromage mais face à part au
niveau de la recherche scientifique est
ce qu'on dit au niveau des risques et la
recherche se poursuit j'imagine oui
effectivement
n'étant pas une alimentation nouvelle
alimentation faible en glucides
l'alimentation cet ogm ont déjà fait
l'objet de beaucoup d'études parce que
effectivement comme l'avait déjà
souligné
c'était connu comme étant un traitement
pour les enfants épileptiques
avant l'invention des médicaments
antiépileptiques mais ce que peu de gens
savent c'est que c'était aussi un
traitement connu contre buy pauvres et
des le diabète avant les mentions de
l'insuline mais également pour traiter
l'obésité est le même mais mou 10e des
dix neuvième siècle c'était quelque
chose qui était bien connu et donc il ya
eu beaucoup d'études et y en a
énormément les études actuelles sur
l'alimentation faible en glucides sur
l'alimentation sept jeunes sont en
explosion
ça fait effectivement ça suscite
beaucoup d'intérêt en fait et donc on
n'a pas encore toutes les réponses à
tout mais ça c'est comme dans bien
d'autres choses
une des bases des diètes en jeu
ce qu'on entend souvent dans les médias
c'est qu'il faut aussi faire de
l'exercice physique en même temps qu'on
suit un régime particulier dans le cas
de la diète cétogène si on réduit les
ligues lucide ça veut dire qu'on manque
d'énergie quelque part ou comment ça
commence que le corps oui c'est se
débrouille avec la notion de l'effort
physique et en fait il faut comprendre
que le corps humain est capable de
carburer avec principalement deux
carburants le glucose peut servir de cas
de carburant mais également les grands
les liquides et donc dans une
alimentation faible en glucides ou une
alimentation saine
cet objet le corps dans le fond carbure
au gras et ce qui est intéressant avec
cette alimentation là c'est qu'ils
carburent au gras que l'on mange mais
également celui que l'on porte dans
notre corps et c'est la logique
bien sûr la de physiologie même 101 si
on se moque des grèves dans notre cas
c'est pour que cette grève plus
éventuellement servir d'énergie en cas
de besoin
mais ce qui se passe pour des raisons
hormonales qui sont assez complexes que
je n'entendis quitteront pas
nécessairement maintenant mais quand on
mange beaucoup de glucides sur une base
régulière
notre corps devient moins bon a brûlé
ses réserves de graisse donc il est
plutôt comme voulu qu dépendant il
dépend du glucose comme source d'énergie
quand on devient faible en glucides ou
cétogène on permet au corps d'aller
brûler ses réserves de graisse
corporelle qui sont là pour être utilisé
au final donc on a toute l'énergie qu'il
nous faut d'ailleurs il ya de plus en
plus d'athlètes de haut niveau qui sont
faites aux jeunes parce que dans une
épreuve sportive comme par exemple le
tour de france où un marathon ça leur
permet d'avoir plus d'endurance de
carburer au à une énergie qu'ils
transportent avec eux mêmes et donc dans
un an dans un régime cétogène est ce
qu'on peut avoir une fois par semaine le
droit de prendre la baguette ou
le droit où il faut toujours toujours
abolir les glucides
bonne question en fait j'aimerais vous
dire qu'avant toute chose
moi je n'appelle pas ça un régime parce
qu'un régime c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait mouche en résultats et alors que le
principe de vendre un des principes de
base de l'alimentation faible en
glucides et cette gêne c'est que c'est
un mode de vie dans le fort bloqué un
peu comme quelqu'un qui devient
végétarien personne lui dit mme avec
l'antenne ce que tu as arrêté ton régime
l'attention des secteurs un mode de vie
donc dans une optique de mode de vie et
dans une optique ou y
la vraie vie qui arrive la réalité on
est à éviter chez des gens il ya des
événements spéciaux la nourriture fait
partie de la culture et de la société de
la façon dont on socialise moins de mon
point de vue personnel et des médecins
c'est que si de temps en temps quelqu'un
veut se permettre une douceur une
gâterie une baguette ou quoique ce soit
d'autre
c'est tout à fait correct pour la
majorité des gens dont c'est à dire on
on prend on mange un coup de baguette
et puis leur foi suivant mais on reprend
dans le fond une alimentation plus
faible en glucides et voilà il faut pas
faire de ces différents chez les gens
qui ont une dépendance à la nourriture
parce que ça te les précipiter un peu
vert dans une chute un peu comme un
alcoolique qui reviennent à temps ou
chez quelqu'un qui a vraiment besoin
d'être enceinte aux nutritionnelle donc
d'avoir des corps cétoniques en
circulation par exemple les épileptiques
qui sont bien contrôlés avec
l'alimentation cet objet massif ont un
écart de ce genre là ils sortent de
cette hausse tu as peut avoir un impact
sur le contrôle de leur maladie mais
pour la majorité des gens non seulement
ces dates et biya et de temps en temps
de jeu correct c'est ok il voit rien
arriver le corps n'explose pas que ce
soit les correct d'avoir un petit écart
de temps en temps mais ça doit demeurer
occasionnels
ok c'est en observant oui comme ceux
situés suffit ouais ça c'est tout à fait
ma dernière question on attend pour une
dernière question de vous préciser moi
j'ai une autre question
ben moi qatar parce que évidemment mais
aussi j'ai quand même eu ce soit j'ai
toujours été un terrain
et par les régimes à j'appelle son
régime le même dixième
il ya eu un temps vous serez très
populaire de remplacer les glucides par
les protéines qui me semble que cela
ressemble un peu à ça finalement le
c'est un gène dans le fond si on prend
plus de protéines somme est associé à du
gros ce comment vous voyez c'est ce
qu'on en fait non ça ressemble plus à
l'est oui et oui il ya eu la mode dit
faible en gros il ya eu la mode du riche
en protéines en fait c'est
l'alimentation faible en glisse et 17
jeunes et les normes aux protéines c'est
à dire c'est déjà bon modéré
entretiennent un peu la même chose que
dit le guide alimentaire canadien comme
ça s'est modérée en protéines que donc
vraiment on fait une bascule on on
diminue nos apports en glucides on
augmente nos apports en lipides et c'est
vraiment les deux principales sources
d'énergie du corps humain les protéines
elles elles demeurent au même niveau et
j'ai une question qui vient de la régie
justement au sujet des protéines
il semble qu'il ya des gens qui font
face est un peu de musculature de
l'autre côté ils veulent savoir quoi
faire si on doit justement faire des
exercices de musculation intense par
rapport à ces questions de protéines
dans une alimentation c'est un jeu
commence con mais c'est un peu comme une
alimentation régulière dans le sens où
dans votre alimentation régulière il ya
des protéines de manière modérée
normalement il a avec votre entraîneur
selon vos besoins ou selon si vous êtes
en faire qu penny ou en croissance
musculaire etc
vous pouvez décider d'ajouter un peu des
protéines autour de votre entraînement
un peu avant pendant ou après
l'alimentation faible en glucides cette
gêne c'est la même chose si vous voulez
augmenter vos apports en protéines
autour de vos séances de musculation
vous pouvez très bien le faire ça ne
fait pas une alimentation qui est restée
particulièrement riche en protéines doit
vous je sais que vous recevez des gens
qui veulent qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent adopter ce régime là c'est ce
que vous faites présentement à votre
clinique n'est ce pas c est ce que c'est
une part importante de des visites que
vous recevez votre bureau en fait moi je
suis médecin de famille à la coiffe de
santé de contrecoeur et dont 90% de la
médecine familiale avec mes patients
un vendredi sur deux je me regarde et je
fais de la médecine metaboli d'ailleurs
je suis sortie et donc et l'alimentation
faible en glucides et c'est agen et une
alimentation qui soutenus et reconnus
par la science et par la médecine de
l'obésité comme étant un traitement
efficace contre l'obésité et contre le
diabète de type 2 ou si évidemment et
donc moi je fais ça un vendredi sur deux
pour me garder principalement fait
tellement d vos résultats que ceux de la
médecine que je voulais passionné de
will genia d'alimentation c'était votre
vendredi sur deux aujourd'hui c'est ça
non ses membres ont compensé en en
parlant vous trichez bien merci nous
avons eu l'information si d'aucuns moi
j'ai reçu ça de ma nièce qui m'a parlé
de ça je trouve ça super sympa alors
c'est d'acteurs evelyne d'abord dû à
roye le médecin de famille si vous
voulez la joindre de la coop de santé et
de solidarité à contre coeur voilà
comment assortir convaincu converti que
je j'allais vous montrer une cure
miraculeuse avec une enfant on parlait
de l'épilepsie de un peu plus tôt merci
on a le temps de présenter cette vidéo
c'est c'était serré sans relativement
récent ses tournées par radio-canada ça
a duré à peine une minute
mais ça vous manque que cette diète elle
a peut-être plus de mérite que de
critiques
aucun cas ce qu'on lit dans les journaux
parfois on écoute saas ou en regardant
on fait du podcasting j'ai appelé sa
guérison miraculeuse et c'est de fait ça
se passe à montréal une jeune fille
plein sont six en a 6 ans a déjà un
lourd vécu jusqu'à l'âge de deux ans et
demi c'était une enfant au développement
normal j'ai dit baba actuellement la
manger dans l'auto sont bégaud en a
parlé en a joué deux heures l'après midi
on reçoit un appel de la galerie qu'elle
avait tombé sur cette photo prise le
matin du 29 ou 2013
on y voit la petite diana souriante
l'oeil allumé quelques heures avant sa
première crise d'épilepsie
ses parents ne la verront plus sourire
de cette façon pendant des mois
liu après de nombreux tests on découvre
qu'elle est atteinte de maladie très
rare une encéphalite auto immunes chaque
jour le nombre de crises d'épilepsie
augmentait pour atteindre jusqu'à 500
par jour
les spécialistes ont tout essayé mais
rien n'y faisait
c'est le jeune neurologue pédiatrique et
médecins de tiana bradley en semaine
centre hospitalier de l'université laval
qui a eu une idée étonnante guérir sa
petite patiente avec un régime
alimentaire cétogène on a construit des
ajouts canada sitôt jeunes 5,6 m6 a eu
des résultats de la convertir
oui c'est pas vraiment d'idée mais on
trouve comme ça mais on va aller on peut
faire des recherches et vous allez voir
que ça mais je dois vous exige que ce je
trouve ça fascinant explosé j'étais rytz
heins expliqué avec ma nièce parce que
c'est une longue conversation noël le
verre de vin et je suis sorti d'un homme
était tellement bonne humeur les
tellement bonne humeur changer
complètement d'attitude plutôt négatives
dans le passé grâce est évidemment
parfaite forme physique d'un une énergie
à revendre alors c'est pour ça que je me
sens bien il faudra faire un travail sur
comment renverser l'idée que mongeon du
grand on va maigrir
là il faudra travailler si kolo sait où
un ballot de recherche
j'ai une autre vidéo la vidéo euro 6 je
sais compter sur les midis doigts de la
main fait un tabac on a pour elle
d'obtenir le numéro 6 et c'est pour vous
montrer ce qui a à la suite de notre
émission aujourd'hui que vous pouvez
écouter ou regarder il ya toujours des
reportages qu'on ajoute sur notre page
web de tam-tam canada je pense qu'on a
cinq ou six cette semaine oui ça c'est
là vous pouvez regarder sans compter les
reportages dans la page parce qu'il peut
avoir une question sur le nombre de
reportages
alors il ya des débordements gingras
faut perdre rapidement du poids la
promesse de la diète c'est aux jeunes ya
déjà quelque chose là graisses animales
saturées maintenant bonne pour votre
santé des rats canadien plein de
malbouffe mélangeant des fibres brestois
plus minces maigrir à tout prix gars
assez diète qui peuvent semer le trouble
et ça c'est bien plus on mange plus
l'appétit augmenté pour ceux qui veulent
perdre du poids ces ouvrages outreau on
s'habitue à manger trop de gras et quand
on coupe
ça diminue moi je suis comme ça des
périodes de ma vie où je perds un peu
l'appétit et c'est une bonne chose c'est
que je serai jamais mauvais de faire un
peu de ce qu'on appelle de la presse a
dirigé des jaunes action n'est pas
finalement la dernière fois en personne
l'a perdu raymond a perdu des points
non non il a perdu des points non non
mais la même réponse du point ben oui
nous on a perdu la première question
donc vous êtes à 80,81 tous les deux et
il est à 100 pour un dernier tour de la
grosse boule on affiche la question 50
boules à perdre
qui dit mieux quel pourcentage des
adultes de 18 à 74 ans au québec
cannabis est sorti la présente un tour
de taille considéré comme un risque je
vous préviens déjà j'ai pris un risque
et m'en a fait un sujet là dessus cette
semaine a donc peut-être qu'il aurait
récemment j'ai référence et ça c'est à
temps les femmes sont rares 70 c'est un
art un oui non c'est 40% comme intention
c'était sa fête du canada
vous avez répondu finalement 40 pour ça
oui alors vous avez tous raison mais sa
balle fait merci beaucoup c'est aussi
simple que ça c'est un bête en
perspective parce que 40% des gens ou ça
m'a étonné moi je
attendez qu'on veuille m'a quand même un
peu la proportion ici non gardé qu'il a
regardé l'écran plutôt s'ajoutent 10 10
kilos s'est dît livre alors écoutez 4 kg
400 g quelque chose que j'adore faire
avec vous en fin d'émission passé le
vendredi force que ça sur la fin sinon
ce serait temps de travail d'ici jeudi
voici la question quelle est l'image
cette semaine alors s'est dressé devant
moi parce que c'est dans le monde du
sport d'abord excusé dans le monde du
sport parce que c'est dans cette
atmosphère que j'y pense là non pas
verra donc on imagine je réponds pas aux
tendons est ce que ces canadiens norba
écouter ça pourrait être international
c'est internationaux que c'est nos
amériques sénat américain parce que
c'est dans notre choix c'est donc là
chaque semaine on peut répondre de
manière simple alors qu'est ce qu'il a
fait cette semaine qu'ils méritent
images la spa
oui il a tenté d'acheter le gouët et
vous avez vu les caricatures qui ont
suivi par le krach ou encore le
groenland qui achèterait le kentucky
font la fête comme ça qu'ils vont se
pourrait bien sûr ils vont aller voir
des banques et la russie est légitime
propriétaire ce qui cause la première
ministre du danemark
il a dit inquiétez vous pas ne vous
inquiétez pas il y aura pas de tour
trompeur grand l'emploi
on l'a vu il ya le seuil a tweeté sale
image 2e tour 30
je me demande si dans le bureau de la
maison blanche y jouer avec photoshop
pour ajouter une photo quand vous voyez
ça sur le prêteur il a un téléphone qui
fait grand chose
en tout cas c'est un cas spécial mais
déjà encore ce matin c'était par rapport
au directeur général de la banque
oui il ay là et c'était vraiment un
agent ou président de l'alpa le
président de la fête la fed c'est ça il
a il a attaqué je sais pas si on va sur
le taux de départ mais il attaqué sur le
taux de ce que tous les électeurs
aujourd'hui toute la semaine il a
commencé à tweeter sont gratuites et aux
majuscules donc là pour montrer un peu
son degré de l'exercice récession c'est
ce qui la faute à c'est la fête à faire
évidemment coûté on va terminer sur une
bonne et les élus démocrates bardot et
les éléments et le canada mais aussi
respect des gens qui n'écoutent pas de
la vérité ce sont les journalistes ne
faut pas donner votre bio font s'envoler
dans votre coin qui est d'accord il y en
a deux autres mon frère
écoutez je havas connaît en on vous
avait dit quelque chose qui va rester
dans les annales de cette émission vous
allez je sais pas si un nouveau gros
mais vous êtes devenu une peau kastina
trice j'ai employé le verbe procrastiner
au présent à la première personne je
procrastine et vous avez aimé le mot
procrastine vous n'êtes pas être doué
mais le son des mots prophète nom au
casting ne la porte pas de casque au du
casting à ça c'est bon vous êtes
tellement bonne là dedans
vous allez nous présenter notre vidéo du
numéro 8 je vous dis pas c'est quoi vous
avez deviné regardant ça les comprendre
tout de suite et c'est pour le bénéfice
de tous nos internautes qui veulent
écouter nos émissions lorsque oui tout à
fait alors nous avons enfin de refonte
de notre plateforme pour les podcasts
d'où les balados effectivement alors
vous allez tout simplement sur notre
page d'accueil au milieu de la page
environ balado et là ça va être très
simple d'accéder à toutes nos entrevues
audio que les journalistes font tous les
jours et aussi à nos émissions
hebdomadaires par exemple on voit ici la
presse amadou et pouvait sur votre
téléphone évidemment donc d'une façon
d'y accéder
les entrevues dans la langue que vous
voulez comme vous savez radio canada
international travaille en cinq langues
français anglais arabe chinois espagnol
l'a très bien voilà alors ça c'est pour
les podcasts badham fantastique
voilà c'est tout y a pas autre chose a
ajouté c'est vendredi vous pouvez vous
défouler mais j'ai avec mes collègues
ajouté il reste encore du travail allait
faire oui vous vous travaillez moi je
m'amuse 10 ou plus en plus ils ont
l'audace de former indice de bonheur au
travail c'est sa toiture nage en plein
bonheur dans le
c'était pas du moment de la journée
s'annonçait ouais ils gagnent des
artistes un boute-en-train les grands
pinceaux dans le magasin en fait nous on
est en fait beaucoup de tap tap a
beaucoup de talent a alors je vous tapez
pas plus et puis on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine merci d'avoir été avec
nous c'est tout le monde
[Musique]